you know again this
with respect to the current case it is
ongoing
um i really can't comment on it um but i
certainly
am happy to address the situation with
i guess the new reporting on this
domestic violence case if i may yeah um
are you for are you able to um
have you been able to see the reporting
from inside jail
frankly i haven't seen much reporting to
be awesome you know but um you know i've
been in constant contact with my wife as
a reason so
uh just give me a little bit of what's
gone on so like but again
i'm not fully
reversed at what's going on but i
uh again i i do want to make sure that i
hopefully clear the air a little bit
with folks on that particular
issue
so what would you like to say about that
so you know i'm
you know frankly i'm somebody who has
adhd
and
you know i've always strived to do my
very best
every day
and
you know unfortunately when you have
adhd sometimes you're prone to
i guess
you know certain behaviors like um
these compulsive behaviors you know when
i was a little boy
i was pretty overweight because i
yeah that was a compulsive eater um
when i got old enough to drink when i
started drinking
um
you know i
when i would drink i'd drink one two and
before you knew it
i would drink way too many and i would
black out
me that i was proud of it's
yeah i always wanted to be like
everybody else
i always wanted to try to
you know
be normal and
be able to have one or two drinks
um
but it seemed that every time that i
would drink i would drink
so quickly and i would black out and i
wouldn't know what i was doing my body
was doing whatever it was doing
it was
you know my wife
after i got married was a very good dad
you know
i guess
you know put up with it it never gets
really bad except for that
unfortunately that one night a couple
years ago um
when i blacked out i
i guess got belligerent enough for my
wife to get scared now i never heard her
or my children
but i scared them enough to
make her call the police
and
you know
from that day forward i
i just stopped drinking i i realized
that i
i just
i couldn't be like everybody else i i
can't just have one or two drinks
because it always led to too many and it
was related to blackouts so would you
say would you say you had a drinking
problem
i guess from the standpoint that if i
ever drank yes i would have a problem
when i drink i didn't drink every day
but
whenever i would pick up
one drink two drinks then it would
quickly slide into way too many and that
would black out
did you use drugs too
we've seen the video from that night
when when police were arresting you
um
obviously the charges were later dropped
and you had to attend the online class
what's your message to your family and
friends from inside jail
well i
you know
this is for me i've always like i said
tried to live my life
being a good person
um
like
folks we all have mistakes that we make
and
you know there were many people who knew
me just for the good works that i've
done
you know um
and
i i believe that there are still those
friends of mine who understand that you
know that i am
generally doing my best
and to all my friends and of course my
family my i love my family so much my
wife my children my parents my siblings
everybody my family i love them all so
much
and
you know i
i i appreciate all of you and
thank anybody who supports me and
it's been very hard
you know this weekend my family and i
were supposed to go to the life is
beautiful
um
you know
obviously
you know
it's been tough
i've been um for that
but
it has been hard
do you know the images they've shown us
you know it obviously had ups and downs
um
i was able to do a lot of good things um
i got laws passed that help families and
we will do a lot of great things at the
office unfortunately you know i also at
the same time had
some folks in the office who just were
not happy with the changes
and
you know
there was a lot of pressure from within
the office
and outside the office
it was certainly a daily struggle
were you aware obviously you were aware
of the reporting that was going on um
what was your reaction to jeff gehrman's
reporting
um you know
obviously this is anybody you know
something like this like
reporting by someone especially when you
know that
the issues aren't that's not true i mean
it certainly was hurtful very very you
know but
again i don't know if i
[Music]
you know
i just don't know how much you should
get into that
i understand that i just you know the
obviously you're you're innocent until
proven guilty and you're in you're in
this situation
um
i'm just i'm just curious what what
you'd like to say
because
right now this is a story about an
elected official who was very mad about
reporting
and you know i'm an investigative
reporter as well
and you know one of my colleagues was i
i don't work at the newspaper but you
know one of my colleagues you're accused
of killing
um
and i and i think this is an opportunity
for you to sort of
maybe help people understand why you're
accused of this
yeah no i you know all i can say is i've
gotten nothing
against the media at large
and i
really can't comment beyond that
um
like i said i've just
really truly tried to live my life day
by day doing the best that i can
what
was going through your mind when all
those police were outside your house all
those reporters were outside your house
last week
you know
i guess it's really hard to put into
words
and i think maybe i'll just
not
i guess
refrain from answering if that's all
right
um
are you
um
are you
prepared to move forward with defending
yourself in court i mean you have a
lawyer but are you prepared to move
forward
i know that there were concerns that you
were harming yourself
how does how does rob tell us move
forward from this
of course
we do look at our legal options and see
where we go
you know
again
the goal
is to ultimately
um
was this
you know
i'm trying to sort of understand a
little more about um you know your your
your thinking the past your pa your past
couple months so
um you know when did you
you go ahead
i don't know i just i i think we've
in my apologies i'm not trying to be
rude but i don't know if
you know there's anything else we can
talk about
if that's right with you well i'm just
curious what you know what life is it is
like for you in there in in
seeing you know i don't i'm i'm curious
what you know about what's happening out
here and then what life has been like
for you and there
yeah i mean i mean again if that's right
i think
i think
again my
all right um final question though what
made you want to
talk to us today
well again you know when
obviously i hear that
my
domestic violence thing came up and
certainly obviously it seems that people
want to make sure to play it up that
in some kind of monster or something
i'm i just want to hopefully set the
record straight say i'm somebody who's
made mistakes
but i'm like i said trying to do my best
day by day
to do the right thing
all right i guess that's it rob
thank you very much for your time i
appreciate it